[Musique]
jean-pierre puisards bonjour bonjour
monsieur livory bonjour aux auditrices
et auditeurs de martinique la première
alors vous êtes candidat du museum le
musée à monsieur le mouvement unifié de
la jeunesse active martiniquaise pro
pour les élections législatives et vous
présentez sur l'a7 transcription du
centre la première c'est conscription
qu'est ce qui a motivé votre candidature
ma candidature
ce qui a motivé ces vaccins n'ont pas
encore de militants
et d'observateurs de la vie politique
depuis je dirais 30 ans et ce qui me
motive particulièrement c'est parce que
je veux travailler pour la postérité
donc pour
les générations futures alors travailler
il faut les générations futures
qu'est ce que cela implique qu'elles
sont vos deux grands projets qu'elle de
votre de vos orientations
tout d'abord
la lutte
contre la pollution des terres par par
le chlordécone donc je pense qu'il va
falloir
activer la recherche à la recherche pour
pouvoir arriver à la dépollution des
sols et des cours d'eau parce que ça a
des conséquences sur la santé has et
notre santé et encore plus sur la santé
des générations à venir donc cancer de
la prostate mais on parle aussi d'un des
mythes d'endométriose et auprès d'autres
maladies qui sont liées à cela et
l'autre fait que je souhaite pour
pouvoir préparer l'avenir et apaisée
apaisé parce que je parle de justice
sociale donc je veux apaiser cette
société et je pense qu'il va falloir
faire un travail
avec la fondation pour la mémoire de
l'esclavagé et je pose est de faire
travailler afin de pouvoir récupérer un
certain nombre d'hectares de terres pour
pouvoir mettre au service
par exemple créer un dmp en foncier très
pouvoir pour les projets structurants
qui seront décidées par les politiques à
l'avenir aussi dans votre
vous dites que vous allez vous si vous
opposer à toute nouvelle demande
d'évolution institutionnelle
absolument tout à fait parce que je n'ai
pas oublié la trahison et la trahison
est d'aider des parlementaires de
l'époque avec la complicité de monsieur
nicolas sarkozy pourquoi parce que les
martiniquais avaient voté j'étais pour
gt pour une fusion des deux
collectivités mais pas pour le
changement de mode de gouvernance parce
que nous avons toujours connu un mode de
gouvernance avec un exécutif qui le
président une commission permanente et
l'assemblée et là on a créé un conseil
exécutif donc déjà ce n'est pas par
rapport à la démocratie c'est opaque et
là entre deux de deux plénières
le conseil exécutif ne peut pas prendre
de décision tandis que lorsqu'il y avait
une commission permanente la commission
permanente pouvait prendre des décisions
donc nous n'avons pas voté j'ai voté
pour cela nous n'avons pas voté pour un
changement de mode de gouvernance même
bien pour une fusion des deux
collectivités et ça je n'ai pas oublié
c'est vrai que beaucoup de gens ne le
savent pas mais ceux qui suivent
vraiment la politique et qui connaissent
donc savent qu'il ya une trahison et en
personne n'en parle et ça je me poserai
par rapport à cela alors vous avez aussi
une autre proposition originale avant un
bureau mobile en investissant dans un
camping car pour faire le tour de la
circonscription c'est ça oui pas
seulement le tout de la seule obsession
parce que ces conceptions encore il est
allé de plus quand les deux communes et
plus vaste donc le lamentin le goût
monde mais les autres communes aux 600
sont assez vastes et c'est ce que je
veux c'est la proximité ça déjà pas
prendre un bureau dans l'une des
communes c'est à dire avant permanence
électorale dans l'une des communes je
souhaite qu'avant le bio qu un bureau un
des os mobiles c'est à dire
le camping-car servira de bureau mobile
à moi et aussi aux attachés
parlementaires qui vont travailler avec
moi alors vous allez parler donc la
justice sociale mais aussi vous voulez
une égalité réelle pour tous oui la loi
pour l'égalité réelle donc elle a du mal
à s'appliquer et la constitution
garantit les mêmes doigts
les mêmes droits qu'eux
les que la france hexagonale et c'est
vrai que là je trouve qu'il y a trop
trop encore ce coup de trop toi
d'inégalités comme je dis souvent la
martinique j'ai l'impression qu'à la
martinique c'est une amoureuse éplorées
et alors que deux régions sont
considérées
je ne vais pas dire comme quoi c'est
vrai que notre cohésion soient
considérés je vais le dire allez comme
des de la république un jeu là
seulement
760 vous propose c'est de libre de
irresponsable de vos propos alors si
vous avez à dire quelque chose à la
population pour qu'elle puisse voter
pour vous couvert convaincre par dans la
population oui donc je dis à la
population que je suis issu du peuple je
demeure avait dans le peuple et je suis
pour le peuple je ne vais pas
je ne vais pas trahir la population je
ne vais pas la trahir
et comme je dirais que moi j'ai fait ma
part et que le reste
voilà d'accord jean-pierre puisards je
vous remercie merci monsieur livory